welcome back everyone
sorry about the gremlins that have been
beset us here in the morrow for the last
little while but it seems like we're
back and we're still with this
incredible scene playing out in this
lugar we've got some more hyenas that
arrived they don't look too excited to
jump into the cold water
oh look at that they brought that one
chase
kaylynn says I just love the hyena
falling in the water while cat and I'm
hoping we get a bit more of it on a bit
more of a spectacular leap and sort of
give them points out of 10 for their
jump into the putrid water our vultures
are having the best time of it that if
they're being chased again the bonus of
flight enabling them not to have to swim
to get to their meal
here we go is the little one gonna be
the first to make the leap being really
exciting chasing each other about two
out
in the river
you
welcome back everyone again apologies
for the technical difficulties this
afternoon there are a huge amount of
very large storms around but one of the
hyenas took the plunge and has now
decided May after a big chunk of rotting
Buffalo that it's probably nicer outside
of the water so again they keep falling
in and out trying to find the way hard
that looks like a much more sensible
place to get out of the water but
there's still two hyenas you haven't
made the plunge it that are scuttling
about on the edge oh here we go
Billy is wondering with the flesh in a
[ __ ] on a carcass rot quicker out of
water or in water I'd say it all depends
on on the climate around so normally I
would say out of water in hot parts of
the Africa like for Jim a a tumor
example but in their cooler parts it'll
probably rot slower in the water I added
hot spots for that matter so I wasn't
making much sense there it's so
incredible watching these vultures oh
look it's doe now joy is wondering what
the lions ever try get on this in on
this enjoy it is a possibility but it
all depends on how hungry they are if
they're hungry enough they definitely
would try get on it but if they're not
they'd probably choose not to eat this
difficult carcass now you might find
Lions might go into the water there to
pull the carcass to the side I have seen
them do that before
let's see if this high you know possibly
does that push it Oh stay away of
vultures have you got a problem solving
I you know is it gate greed and food
gonna get the better of it before it
manages to push it into the shallow
water
hello Francis in Israel Francis's there
must be really really hungry to be doing
this
not at all Francis a hyena is the
ultimate opportunist and they have no
problem eating absolutely putrifying
rotten meat and their stomachs are able
to handle it and this is a lovely easy
free meal for them they're also quite
big fans of water so it's a double bonus
for them Dave is wondering other
vultures safe from the hyenas their
diners will chase the vultures but it's
very very seldom they actually ever
catch one see come on can't eat and
balance on a carcass at the same time
and you can see that the rain is
starting to fall a little bit where we
are
you'd think the hyenas would push it
towards shallower water and then make it
much easier for them to feed on it
apparently a lot of people are saying
yak yak yak wow I think I might go for a
swim in there just now no of course I'm
only joking that water is very very
smelly now that little one is it finally
going to make the plunge
Kathy is wondering are hyenas strong
enough to pull it completely out of the
water
they are Kathy most definitely maybe not
yet but once it breaks up a little bit
but they could definitely with the
buoyancy of the carcass I sort of push
it towards the shallow aside and here we
go see it's it's a floating I'm floating
Buffalo
it buffalo carcass that's possess it
alive and this can't be gone Oh
lost sight of it for now it it's the one
biting everyone else can see it's a
slightly bigger than the other vultures
and it's got that pale beak Dave is
wondering am I sure the Buffalo wasn't
struck by lightning I'm not David but I
don't know how the Buffalo died I
spotted the vultures and hyenas from a
distance and came in here so we also
need to get a bit of rains I'm just
lifting up the windscreen and we have
closed up the one side of our vehicle
but it looks like we might get engulfed
from both sides by storms Oh next
vulture crash oh dear
and out again now is the little I you
know gonna chase it for good measure why
not
emesis I'm gagging just at the thought
of the smell well yes it's not the best
smell I've ever smelled em I won't lie
to you but if your eye you know or a
vulture it's an absolutely delicious
smell it's it's as good as a three-star
Michelin restaurant
giraffes intricacies do I think the
Buffalo might have fallen in while
trying to get a drink I don't there's a
lot of areas on the side of the the
little river that the Buffalo could have
very easily walked up to you along here
and no problem at all
Oh [ __ ] what are you doing I has
some more vultures just landing so there
could be a bit of competition there's a
nice one coming in now John yeah landing
gear out dig dig dig dig dig then is the
law you know frustrated because it
hasn't tried to take the leap for some
rotting Buffalo so it keeps chasing the
vultures around now the hyena dens not
too far from yeah and that's a little
worse sub-adults probably just under a
year or so old
ladybird would like sir is that a mini
waterfall well a waterfall might be a
strong world I'd say a little drop
possibly yes I'm in the little lager
okay so I think we're going to say
goodbye to oh wait all our friends
who've joined us for this action
broadcast and we're gonna say goodbye
others to check for a bit longer see
what else gets going see if more hyenas
arrive so you never know when we could
go live so from myself and Joey it's
been great hopefully we'll see you but
soon you never know we might find Lions
hunting five minutes down the road but
toodaloo for now and and back with me so
hey I sounds like brent has been having
the most amazing time with his hyenas it
really really does I've given up on
trying to predict which way the storms
blow and in this place I could have
sworn that storm was coming straight at
us
but it's blown away and it's actually
headed more in Brent's direction and
left us with almost patches of blue sky
so I put one side up put left one side
down in the hope that oh goodness
sorry arch in the hope that somehow
that's covering both of our bases and if
the storm hits then we can cover up
quickly I don't know I give up I can't
see when the covers are down
we can't keep dry when the covers are up
no sign of the angle MERS I've been
searching for them while you've been
with friends I've been looking in all of
their favorite places and I just can't
find them all this roads a mess rainy
rainy miss wait a minute this isn't the
road I want to be on
it is the road I want to be offered
that's a really very good question from
possibly toady possibly somebody else I
couldn't really hear LS there but it's a
very good question about Tony it was
Tony why it is the animals migrate out
of Amara when it's so green at this time
of year and that is a really very good
question and the answer is because it's
even better
essentially it's even better where they
migrate to so they've done away with
most of the grasses in this area and
they go across and it's Nature's Way of
ensuring that a place doesn't get over
utilized so it's not remember not every
animal migrates it's just the million
odd million class wildebeest and and
good 100 a couple of hundred thousand
zebra but not all of them migrate so a
lot of them stay here are pretty nurse
sorry
watch a lot of them stay in this area so
it's still being utilized but it's
Nature's Way of ensuring it's not over
utilized because there are places in the
Mara when the wildebeest came through in
the numbers that they did it looked like
a fire had been through and if they
stayed in those massive numbers it would
have done eventually quite serious
damage to the grass but grasses are
meant to be grazed but not too much so
they go back with his good quality
grasses to the South back into Tanzania
and then they give birth
haha David says the grass is always
greener on the other side that is
essentially hard work so they're
basically bounce backwards and forwards
to oversimplify a considerable amount
they basically bounce backwards and
forwards they eat all the grass and then
they comes over us and then they do it
again essentially right as we continue
on our search for the Lions as I said I
think prince is having the most amazing
time with his hyenas let's go back
across them and see if they are enjoying
a floating dining room
a13 diamond indeed the problem for this
little hyena the one who sort of been
aiming and hiring about getting in is
it's not quite as tall as the others so
it can't put its back legs on the ground
and while feeding and the fetching
dining room tends to move from time to
time and especially when the vultures
land on it it sends the hyena sort of
plummeting under the water and isn't
very upset when that happens and it is
enjoying it immensely at the moment the
others have just flopped down in the
grass around here and they'll possibly
feed off this carcass for a couple of
days here we go another one is appeared
oh I want that climbing up
dimitri is wondering are hyenas still
considered to have the strongest bite in
the animal kingdom not in the animal
kingdom but in the mammalian thoroughly
miserable when it's swimming around but
in the mammalian kingdom yes they have
the strongest bite force over 900 pounds
oh yeah see the vultures spun it around
and the boy struggling oh come on climb
back on get onto that rotten smelly
Buffalo slipping again
and the vultures now got itself in a
prime position yes there we go safely on
for now the floating carcass and it's
starting to rain a bit harder now
Kestrel Fox bobbing for Burbine oh dear
oh you nearly went over again now what
really need is another hyena to join in
the fun and from the opposite side and
see you can keep sort of balance the
Buffalo based
vulture stop moving the carcass and
let's see how long it takes for that
candy says hyenas look adorable when wet
let's see how long it takes for the
vultures to join again
well next time you know looks like it's
gonna take the plunge making funny
noises before it does mmm
cold cold I mean for a more sensible way
to approach the water's edge
[Laughter]
jessica is wearing two vultures also eat
everything even the bones Jessica the
vultures aren't able to to break bones
with their beak well this is the first
tight unit who's used the easy way in
still doesn't look too excited about
going any further just yet first it's
going to add add some urine to their to
the mix of rotting Buffalo that is in
the water at the moment maybe they're
trying to warm it up a tad before going
deeper it really looks like someone who
doesn't like the cold who's trying to
ease their way into into a swimming cold
swimming pool
Dave says go on little man Dave I'm not
sure whether it's a little man or a
little girl but I'm sure there is a
little drop off at some point because
I've seen adult hyenas underwater yes a
little bit further forward
there we go slowly slowly I think it's
going to be very funny when it finds
that deeper hole
giraffe centric says this is so
interesting and so funny at the same
time it is a fascinating sighting and it
is always wonderful to see stuff you
don't see every day
serve or is says that Hawaiian is
probably thinking water equals
crocodiles
well these Mara hain has spent a lot of
time in water well there we go Oh deeper
Oh
are you gonna try scuttle for the side
now
[Laughter]
you've just got a little bit of floating
meat that's come off their Buffalo
without having to go all the way into
the deep water oh you're gonna keep
moving
James is wandering with jackal do the
same thing I don't think so James and
Jacqueline we wouldn't go this deep into
thought of their much feed off it of
it's right on the edge but not in
plunging like that now let's see if two
hyenas could all flight feed on a
floating Butler or they're going to end
each other no complaining at the one
that's just arrived now we just need the
third one up top to just bomb drop onto
the Baffler
oh there we go upset the applecart
deciding no this is not fun alrighty
yeah
hi Lily he's six years old nice to have
you with us today Lily Lily says they
should just eat the birds and they
wouldn't get so wait yes I agree Lily
but unfortunately for them the birds are
quite quick and always just manage to
keep out of their way and well they
don't have to well if this one is
fighting to go try get to the Buffalo
but normally with that buffalo carcass
it's much easier the meats nice and
rotten so it's soft so they don't have
to chew too much because I think of all
shell so it probably doesn't taste quite
as nice as a as a buffalo are we going
to get another leap
come on you can do it jump jump
hello joy is in hongkong and joy is
wondering why there are so few hyenas
joy the rest of them actually quite
close by they're just having a nap
they've probably been feeding on this
carcass all day and there's quite a few
adults these are all sort of sub adults
and but the rest of them are lying in
the long grass around here so they are
probably close on ten it's the vulture
away climb back onto your Buffalo there
we go
it's probably I'll probably 1012 hyenas
around yep so there are quite a few
hyenas we just can't see all of them at
the moment because they're in the long
grass
the brown fox is wondering how fast our
hyenas in comparison to vultures you
knowbut of tripity tripity yep so
vultures are quite quick and they can
take off quite quickly and that's
obviously a development from being able
to avoid predators around carcasses but
more specifically for lions but for
hyenas there's no real reason for them
to really attack and kill a vulture just
to try to keep them away from the
carcass I'm just gonna move the car
slightly just to change the drop so it's
not dripping in
time so now move a little bit we'll be
back with those hyenas in a second just
trying to stop the the rain dripping in
on me and more importantly on some of
our electronic equipment here we go
EP is wandering with this watering hole
have a leash I don't know and I don't
plan to find out anytime soon either but
it is possible I know they're leeches in
Lake Victoria which is not too far for
me I'm sure these are leeches in the
Mara River as well but you've got lots
of different types of leeches and in
this part of Africa as far as I'm aware
most of the leeches are the small very
small sort of half a centimetre also in
size and they don't take too much blood
but I have had big leeches on me in the
Central African rainforests before
and then seems to have found at the
right sort of spot to be able to balance
and eat at the same time without falling
over for now
kellen once known as any health risk to
the hyenas for eating a buffalo in that
state of decay and in the water
no hyenas will eat stuff that's far more
rotten than that there they are
evolved to do that this is the
ecological niche so now they are quite
happy eating stuff that's even worse
than that and so a vulture saw a lion so
elected they're all able to eat
completely putrid meat dang greeny
smelly literally green slime meat that
sort of just disappears they can all eat
that but good news while i unit
continues to munch upon this decaying
Buffalo let's go across to Jamie who's
got some kitty cats
I found one kitty cat but it's quite a
big kitty cat so it comes as a
tremendous relief now the storm has
blown away we've come across towards the
how do I describe this the lugger that
runs between the little Governors
entrance and all allure gate or at least
towards oh listen listen listen she's
calling
listening 30 is one of the Martian
breakaway lionesses she stopped calling
for now calling for the rest of her
pride and I know this line is one of the
life one of the three marsh breakaway
lionesses so this is the pride that we
regularly see around here they've got
some gorgeous Cubs I don't see any sign
of the rest of them when I first arrived
she was looking across at a herd of
buffalo I'm not sure how hungry she is
odd I don't know if it's because we
we're not often here so we don't watch
them enough we don't observe them enough
it is an area where we can't off-road so
we can't often get a lot of the time we
can't get close to them but this is the
third time I found one lioness all by
herself and calling for the rest of the
pride in this exact spot almost within a
couple of meters or 50 meters radius why
why does that always happen unless
there's one Linus that keeps coming into
heat or Easter us because she doesn't
have Cubs because that would sort of
explain it if she keeps getting
separated while she's mating and then
she's trying to find them again because
not all of a lot of 3 lionesses have
Cubs so maybe that's why but I don't
know I'm not certain on that that's
speculation
pure and simple Maggie you want to know
if lionesses are ever solitary yes
occasionally almost in fact invariably
under some kind of tragic circumstance
so what I mean by that is the rest of
their pride has been killed or they've
tried to get away with Cubs and from a
male take over and then the Cubs have
died and they haven't managed to regroup
with their pride they are not naturally
solitary beings a natural unit of lions
is a pride
they don't like to spend time on their
own they don't like to be solitary and
you'll see it even when a lioness is
mating with a male to be honest in the
times that I've seen them although they
accepted with a sort of calm resolution
they do still want to be with the rest
of the pride mule watch the male blocks
the female all the time while she's
trying to rejoin the rest so their
natural state is is social so to see a
lioness on their own it's usually quite
a tragic situation and occasionally you
get stories of loan line necessary
there's so many flutterings her my
taillights and I'd keep trying to fly
into my face occasionally you hear tales
of lionesses on their own because the
rest of their pride is being killed by
people which is utterly tragic for
whatever reason whether it's through
poison or they've been hunted killed as
retribution for damage to livestock now
that's not something that we'd encounter
here I can safely tell you that this
lioness is not on her own she is at the
moment but the rest of her pride will be
around possibly further up the lugger he
you know she she's calling to them but
she's not really making a huge effort
yet she will tonight I imagine when it
comes time to reunite but I think we're
going to sit with her until we've summed
up the situation properly I don't see
any other vehicle so it doesn't look
like anybody else has found the rest of
the pride and I can guarantee there'd be
vehicles because there'd be Cubs there
so people would be around hey pretty
girl you are lovely looking listening
the three males or three of the kits
where males or somewhere around this
region I know this because I was told so
that's actually why I came in this
direction was to try and find them let's
try and get a bit around towards the
front of her head the front of her head
that doesn't make any sense and it's
just get a better angle is what I was
going for
perhaps your call softly for us again
and if we're really lucky we might even
see the reunion don't know why she's on
her own though Oh sitting right on the
edge of a bank let me just do a beer
with me I'm just gonna go ahead and then
turn around and come face the other way
you're a quick chick make sure there's
no lines here
Dave she looks like an older lioness oh
she's falling she looks like an older
lioness to me let's have a look at her
teeth
such a stunning or inspiring song
now she's gonna listen for them to call
back last time this happened the other
lionesses listened that they never
actually responded how beautiful is that
francis from israel you say it sounds
like if she was she's in pain I don't
think she is I think she's absolutely
fine I really do
it's just her just the way that she's
calling now she's listening very very
intently or the sound of the response I
said she was an older lioness but now
that I look at her teeth I've changed my
mind I don't think she is that old tatty
is often a sign that there are or that
an animal is a bit older but not always
she's got quite a dark nose but she's
also got very very intact teeth and they
don't look overly yellow I'll find out
for you it shouldn't take me too long to
find out I can research that pretty
quickly now that I know which which
pride she belongs to
Alice I'm so sorry I'm struggling to
hear you what was that name Gus Gus Gus
apologies now Gus is how far can lions
call for each other they can call their
calls will cover a distance of
potentially it depends on the
temperature and the ambient conditions
and where they are in terms of the
layout of the land obviously if they're
in a dip then their call is not going to
travel as far because the sound is
absorbed by the land around them but
you're looking at on average between 5
and 10 kilometers possibly even more
remember that their hearing is so so so
much more sensitive than ours a lion's
roar louder something I learned from our
viewers he's a hundred and fourteen
decibels she might just call again she's
still listening intently there's no
there's no sign or any sort of noise
around her there's no calling in
response lots and lots of Buffalo around
but they're not too bothered they know
that she's there they've seen her so you
will you'll have seen them around behind
her just listening no I think she's
going to an eighth term I tell eights
everywhere
I think she's might just call again so
let's just sit patiently with her for a
second
I've seen those - on her own almost
always
I could remember 2003 shears
okay I'm gonna rack my brains because I
know this line is I know her well I know
she's part of the marsh breakaways I'm
just trying to remember which individual
she is so while I figure that one out
and its head across to Brent and find
out if his afternoon is continuing in
the same vein in which it began well it
is that we're still playing well not so
much patience we're just enjoying
because there's another high unit that's
just arrived that looks very interested
in jumping into the water but again it's
sort of that hesitant oh should I turn I
should I should lie I must be so
tantalizing because the caucus is so
close
come on you can do it jump jump into the
cold water
so close yet so far
now the brown fox is asking what is the
difference between male and female hyena
well it's sometimes quite difficult to
tell the difference between them
especially in a scenario like this but
oh we're sneaking so because the female
hyenas have pseudo penises and pseudo
testes and very high androgen levels and
can be bigger than the male hyenas so it
can be quite difficult to tell the
difference between them but other than
that the male has a real penis and real
testicles whereas a female has pseudo
testes and a pseudo penis the pseudo
penis is actually an enlarged clitoris
and they don't have a normal birthing
canal like at most female mammals they
actually give birth through through that
pseudo penis and it is also almost well
every single one of their first litters
every female you know has a litter of of
Cubs the first litter dies because that
canal is is quite quite small and quite
tight in it and they actually suffocate
and only normally the second litter of
Cubs that has born survive now there
could be some apart from the fact that
they need to open up that that system so
that the Cubs can pass it could be an
evolutionary advantage that during that
first let's other females maybe not old
enough or experienced enough to care for
Cubs so then once she has a second
better she's probably in a better
position to be able to raise those Cubs
successfully but generally the biggest
difference you can tell with the
Highnesses they behave behavior the
females are rampantly more dominant over
the males and will often beat them up so
your lowest ranking female hyena is
still higher ranking than the highest
ranked male in the clan
Lady Bird is wondering there's a wet
hyena smell worse than a wet dog indeed
it does much worse well and this your
dog has been eating rotting meat
strangely and I've heard I have spotted
dog that's been eating rotten meat and
smells quite well but definite away
taina smells a lot worse now now what
happens is that a lot of people a lot of
a lot of people you have their domestic
dogs at home think that their dog would
never do this what this hyenas doing at
the moment and I won't mention any names
but there's quite a well-known lady who
is Ben he lives in that in a small town
in northern Botswana where I grew up and
she was the only person there who had
French poodles white immaculately
groomed French poodles and a donkey died
in the Tamil Akane River in front of her
house and with all the village dogs that
were getting stuck in the water with
this rotting donkey there were two not
sir white French poodles after their
being inside the stomach area of the
donkey fighting the local village dogs
off so your domestic dog at home would
do exactly the same as these hyenas with
just as much rotten with the meats just
as rotten Oh have you got a waterfall
jumper are you going to jump off the
ward for now I think we're probably
gonna move on from here now and see if
we can find any lions or whatever else
might be here might pop back in here a
little bit later see as the more hyenas
have arrived and there's more leaping
off the ward for Minnie Ward falls into
there into the putrid water that we know
for sure is full of rotting Butler and
some hyena urine and so far but I'm sure
there's probably quite a lot vulture
dung as well okay so we're gonna move
off and while we do that we're gonna
send you back to Jamie who seems to
figured out the mystery of that lioness
Kimmy
her name is Kimmy it just driving me
absolutely mental because I knew I knew
her so it was within this pride we've
got G Cho meaning I Achille and Kimmy
Achilles the youngest I haven't seen her
in a while I've seen Duccio a few times
but that is who we're looking at so
Kimmy I can find out her age for you
because quite a huge amount is actually
known about at the marsh pride and of
course therefore the marsh
Breakaway lionesses now she's got very
very very distinctive ears and that's
how I recognise her it was driving me
absolutely crazy because I knew I'd seen
her before
you see those notches particularly out
of her right ear so if I had to guess
I'd put her somewhere around seven eight
years old but I'm not sure I'm not sure
exactly how old she is if I remember
correctly
Achille I think is her daughter oh is it
I can't remember
there's so many different facts and line
prize that we have to try and remember
that to keep them straight in our heads
initially it can be a confusing thing
but I know that she's from the Marche
breakaway females I know her name is
Keaney as for where chee-chaw and
Achille are well that's a different
question I've just been watching the
cars investigate Kimberly you say good
job for solving the mystery thank you I
should have actually solved it a long
time ago it was just one of those blank
moments where I could remember seeing
her knowing exactly where I saw her and
it was actually me who solved any kind
of a mystery I got that information from
Stan Starr who runs one of the who's a
very Maura enthusiast and actually runs
one of the groups the Facebook groups on
the big cats of Amarra he was the one
who told me exactly which lioness this
was so I mean it's largely thanks to
them that this was known about them no
sir I think I'm about to get in trouble
for being two meters off the road let's
find out
give me one second Joba nobody I
so we have solved the mystery of the
lioness there we got no trouble at all
I was actually turning round I don't
mean to park here but then she started
roaring and it sort of just kind of
happened so we've solved the mystery but
actually technically I don't claim any
credit for that and Sandy was the one
who actually what is that can you see it
there arch what on earth is that can you
see it
no no no sorry not the car hold on I'm
gonna have to move us what is that a
trip sucker
is it a pig no Kotb
is that there sorry over there
no no no no no no don't disappear don't
do this to me there's spirits running
over there can you see it looks okay
I've lost it there it is can you see it
it's a dog it's a dog I'm just gonna
catch the rain just quickly sorry arch
can you you can come back I've got a
race to catch the Rangers they've just
come past me it's a dog I knew it was a
dog
right the immediate urgency with a
situation like this as the dogs walked
in from the communities when a dog walks
in from communities it could just be
lost it could also be it's going
straight in there it could also be
disorientation from rabies so there are
no fences between the reserve and the
pup obviously you can see that dog it's
wandered in I'm gonna catch up with the
Rangers to tell them because I've got to
tell them immediately
you can't cannot cannot have dogs
wandering around in the Barra Triangle
come back I've got phone numbers
I've got phone numbers to call off sorry
arch but that dogs gonna disappear into
the forest
it's not the first dog I've seen but
most of them are very close to the
villagers
flashing my lights in the hope that it's
going to attract their attention I just
want I don't want the line is to see it
okay guys I'll be with you in a second I
just have to go and catch up with the
Rangers and I want to tell them
immediately and possibly help them find
it again so bear with me I'm gonna send
you over to Brent so that I can have
this conversation with them stop
hello welcome back well that's a little
bit sad but as we've explained in the
past before domestic dog is a really big
threat in a wildlife area so a very good
friend of friend of ours has did his
master's thesis on rabies and one of the
first signs of rabies which only came
out from his master's thesis is
confusion in domestic dogs so basically
the further you find a dog away from its
home the more in a wildlife area
basically I think it's every five
kilometers eating that the chance that
it has rabies increases by 20% so that's
why Jamie is getting a hold of the range
is quite quickly there and of course
rabies is a very very dangerous disease
especially in social animals like lions
and hyenas because they're so social
that if one of them gets it it can go
through a whole population or a whole
Pride a whole clan very quickly so
that's why it needs to be dealt with
bronte
ah now I know this this spot it doesn't
look so bad but it is
so it's quite deep
well what pi see what I mean there we go
okay so while we meander on our we're
going to switch across to the juma
stream which seems to be more stable and
hopefully will help deal with saw
gremlins so bear with us for a few
minutes while Juma start up their side
so toodles will see you just now
good afternoon everyone welcome to South
Africa to the sabi sands to Juma
I am Noelle and on camera I have said
hello sub he says hello so it is 26
which is an 80 degrees Fahrenheit and we
have a little bit of a blue sky that was
showing with a bit of clouds beautiful
puffy puffy puffy clouds lots of insect
activity with all of this bit of
overcast but it's nice and warm it's
slightly humid from all the the moisture
that we've been having and hopefully
tomorrow with a bit of sunshine
everything's gonna be even more green
than it already is so seven I are busy
gonna go check the western side of our
property I'm not quite sure what I feel
like seeing today I'm kind of in the
mood for wild dogs again but while I'm
busy trying to find something wonderful
to show you Ralph has already found
something cheeky too for you to see good
afternoon everybody and welcome on our
afternoon game drive here on Juma
concession in the sabi sands of the
Kruger National Park in South Africa
it's a lovely afternoon my name is Ralph
Kirsten and please join us on Twitter
hashtag Safari live and on the youtube
live chat at the moment we've just
started out and we've we found some
monkeys they are feasting on the on the
the flying answers we call them even
though they aren't ants like termites
all the a lights have come out and they
are exiting their their nests and
they're forming an amazing food source
so we're going to see all sorts of birds
and monkeys coming to feed on them and
we just stop Joe we saw a whole host of
monkeys
they literally sit right in front of the
hole
then they start to feed on the termites
as they come out the hall we also see a
lot of the frogs and things like that
I like lizards etc and they go right in
front of the hole and they start to feed
on it so we've been looking out for a
couple of small little things like this
feeding on on the termites lovely source
of protein now this afternoon's game
drive we're going to be looking for for
the big cats the rain that we have had
is gonna have washed all their markings
away and so I'm pretty sure that a lot
of the lipids are gonna be out remarking
their territories and as VMs just showed
you there there's still a little bit of
a chance of rain however it is a nice 20
degrees around 70 70 degrees Fahrenheit
in that in that region it is fluctuating
as the clouds come and go as the Sun
pokes through but our aim for this
afternoon's Drive is to look for some of
the Predators moving around but with
this amazing food source coming out
there's also going to be all sorts of
smaller things that we can we can stop
and have a look at so I'm gonna start up
and move on a little bit these monkeys
have moved off a little bit because of
our presence they are some Impala up in
front here so we might and then as I say
we're going to get onto the track of
these big cats the sticks pride and in
coomer's have been around but they up in
the northern parts near Buffalo K so
we're not too sure that we're gonna
catch up with them just yet however I
think the leopards are going to be
showing themselves quite early this
afternoon trying to re-establish those
territories so as we pull up here I'm
just going to switch off because we can
see some of these lovely young Impala up
front
nice little babies we're seeing a whole
host more of them at the moment so
please far away your questions and your
comments
and there's that little youngster look
he's still not so sure on his feet just
yet but everything seems to have enjoyed
the overnight rain and we've had a whole
host of different insects and reptiles
at all the tortoises were out on the
road this morning and it's almost like
the animals have come out of their holes
after the rain and everything's starting
to show itself again so it's a it's a
very exciting time to be out on this
afternoon's game drive because I think
we're gonna we're gonna find some
amazing sightings and those little
babies even though they're so young they
already start to have their little head
butts alright let's move forward a
little bit and let's see what these
Impala might show us we did hear off
onto the onto the southern side of
youngster said that he spotted these
monkeys again let's have a look
let's see those monkeys were feeding
lovely on there on all the flying
termites remember they're going out now
to start their their new colonies taking
with them the spores from the the
mushrooms that they need to cultivate
underneath the ground so they're going
to be going out and starting the new
colonies as monkeys they all after those
two mats you know we can also eat these
termites they taste very much like
peanut butter and an extremely good
source of protein so with these monkeys
having seen that then our exiting their
the holes they'll also be after that and
something quite interesting that we
often think about if you if you watch
monkeys generally humans can eat almost
everything that monkeys can eat
so if you see monkeys eating something
it's generally safe for humans to eat as
well they've got a very similar stomach
acid to us however if you see baboons
eating certain things you must not mimic
the Boone's because they can eat things
that we cannot so it will turn your
stomach inside out
poisonous things that they'll be able to
digest but not as human so if you'd like
to know what we can feed on you mimic
monkeys they show us the way yes
everybody mentioning our cuteness little
monkeys and as I say he's going to be
chasing all those lights the primary
reproductives they'll be coming up the
nest and lovely food sorcerer he's just
gone behind that bit of brush there
they're all chasing the a lights Donna
how do I know that termites taste like
peanut butter well because I've eaten
quite a few of them we've also set like
the monkeys I do consult with Sidda
myself a bird of a monkey we've also set
eating these termites as they come out
they could rather tasty and some of the
local people what they actually do is
they fry them up and they actually
tastes quite nice so if you ever had a
loss for bar snacks or anything like
that and there's a lot of termites
coming around especially at night around
the the lights you should ever try and
not too bad okay so I'm going to be
carrying on looking out for all these
these little things and see what all the
termites are going to attract but I
think doel has something else with wings
to show you I do have something to show
you I have a woodland Kingfisher there
you could just hear it there but it was
sitting so beautifully with the most
gorgeous light on it and of course as
birds do it just flew away it's alright
there's there's two of them there was a
pair and then there was a third one that
came in and was busy trying to get in
into that little scenario there and it
didn't quite work out
the way that any of them were hoping so
I can still hear them in the background
we're gonna maybe maybe be able to get
another visual right now I just want to
check the western boundary and see if we
have any tracks from those wild dogs
coming in and out cuz I haven't been on
the property for I think about a week
now so we're about due to have some some
wild dogs so I'm just gonna turn the
vehicle around and we will head up that
way and cross fingers and hold thumbs
that not only do we get tracks but maybe
they just want to come running down the
road in our general direction and give
us a bit of a show which would be nice
for everybody involved
today's been slightly slightly quiet I
know this morning it's a really great
insect activity and a few little bookies
and here in that it seems as if
everything big and hairy has gone to
ground it is Sunday you never know maybe
they're off having a rest day so when we
check roads like what I'm doing now
basically for leopard we're looking in
these sort of little drainage systems
you just saw me go down see if they're
crossing over not that they always cross
in the drainage systems but it's a good
place to start and then for something
like wild dog look they might cross
straight over but it's they generally
like to to come straight down a road as
well and it also depends on what they're
after and and what their purpose is if
they're coming over for hunting it could
be a little bit different
Phillipa you're wondering what is the
status of African wild dogs in the
Kruger Park these days so it's about the
same as everywhere else in sub-saharan
Africa they're highly highly highly
endangered the last numbers I had for
the whole continent is about 3,500
probably just under I believe the
numbers for the Kruger Park area sits
somewhere between 250 250 and 300 sorry
sorry this is a little bit of a bumpy
patch um and and so there's not many
left unfortunately um I do know that
there's a concerted effort to do a lot
more research on them
a friend of mine started something
called latest sightings and specifically
latest sightings Kruger and I know from
chatting with him and shine with some of
the research guys that has actually
helped with the research in the Kruger
National Park because before it was just
one or two guys having to traverse 2
million hectares so that's about four
million four and a half million acres
it's a huge property you can fit Israel
inside of Kruger National Park it's
ginormous and now because of this app
that was created and people add
sightings onto there it is it allows the
the wild the wild dog researchers to
gain more information so I know that
that has helped quite a bit
another thing that's kept the numbers
down is the fact of just human
encroachment so the more humans push in
towards wildlife areas the more they
bring things like dogs with them and
dogs bring with them canine distemper
and rabies and
and
just the normal interaction between
predators is also an issue for numbers
as it back sorry about that just lost a
little bit of signal through that dip
there mm-hmm so I think in general the
status is better than it has been oh my
goodness we have a duiker are you gonna
stay in the road or no he's just gonna
cross the road let's see if we can sneak
up and maybe he'll stay put for us to
get a nice visual so in general the
status of wild dogs is better than it
has been but it's still not excellent it
is still something that we have to
monitor and keep an eye out for all
right so that's there I can just see
this little duiker
said let me know when you want me to
stop it's just here at our 11 o'clock
it's gonna push up to our 10 o'clock
just now see there all right don't move
tiger stay where you are
they usually small antelope like this
either want to freeze or they want to
run away now this little fellow here is
being very nice to us and at least
allowing us a little view of its behind
before it runs away so I say fellow has
tiny little horns the females don't have
any there you can just see them there
and he is a browser carrying on eating
leaves with a very strict territory him
and his mates they mate for life will
hold on to their territory together
sorry he's just gone behind the little
thickets there you can see how well his
camouflage blends in and a Ralph was
discussing with you guys this morning
and we did it with our niala
about the colors of antelopes and how
they blend into their surroundings let
me just see if I can back up a little
bit and get another view
there we are so the tawny color with a
little bit of lighter color underneath
fantastic doing a little bit of sin
tamarkan there there's a little
pre-orbital gland a little gland that's
right under the eye it's the thing that
looks similar to a duiker as a
klipspringer it's a little bit smaller
and they use that gland under the eye
quite a lot they stick sticks in it and
put the the gland secretions on the
stick it almost looks like tree sap when
it hardens but as you saw that duiker he
went right up to the tree and then just
sort of rubbed the scent there and
that's to make sure that no other males
come into his little territory or
females possibly for that matter
very very quiet as it walks they do
similar we were chatting this morning
about knee allas doing track on track
walking so putting one foot down and the
next foot in in the same spot and
duikers will do that as well not a
hundred percent of the time but a good
portion of the time again to minimize
the sound they make in the bush
there that's a beautiful view I think
that's probably the best view of a tiger
I've had in a while thank you said he's
looking a little bit sitting for my
liking but I mean look it's it's
difficult to to get all the the
nutrition that you need in the in the
dry season um it is a little bit of a
push not that he's sick by any means but
a little bit they're usually a little
bit more round a little bit more rotund
and it's interesting I mean we're
looking at some leaves now not every
leaf is edible joy you're curious to
know why he wouldn't want females in his
territory because usually joy with the
territoriality it's him and his female
and his mate for life that are
territorial together and so that would
be the reason but that being said I mean
let's say maybe his his partner passes
away then he wouldn't mind a female
coming through but I'm sure they have a
little bit more of an advertisement for
something for a scenario that that would
work through that but yeah it's the
territoriality is usually the the pair
together these smaller antelope species
tend to do mating for life klipspringer
duiker steamed bulk dick dick mate for
life and allows them to have their own
little corner of the bush and to monitor
this corner of the bush and to function
within that that little space quite well
as opposed to something that's larger
like Impala or niala
or kudu that function within a sort of
herd structure or a bachelor herd
structure and and roam a little bit
farther because they're a larger group
not just the two okay down our bumpy
road we go
whoo so speaking of wild dogs and
speaking of domesticated dogs that can
affect wildlife Jaime is up in the Mara
and has seen a feral dog or or possibly
a rabid dog depending I'm not quite sure
let's head up to her and see what
updates she has for us on that situation
all desperate to know exactly what's
happened let me try and explain the
whole situation now that it wasn't such
a rush I really really wanted to get to
the Rangers as quickly as possible
because I know how difficult it's going
to be to find this dog again so chances
are chances are it's just a dog that
wandered in from one of the communities
there's there's a lot of there's a
closed village not far away from here
obviously it's closed there's a village
up at the top of the escarpment there
are dogs around domestic dogs some feral
dogs and they do put her about and do
their own thing it's very very unusual
to see them here because this entire
place has got the most amazing ranger
system to make sure that something like
that doesn't happen but of course
sometimes things slip through the cracks
as I said chances are it's just a lost
little dog there is a possibility that a
small possibility that it is a rabid dog
and because rabies causes disorientation
it's one of the early symptoms and dogs
don't tend to stray outside of their
territory so it's always a little bit of
a warning sign when it's come wandering
in but it could also have had a fight
with another male or something and come
this way so it was really quite
essential just on that small small off
chance we notified the Rangers I caught
them fortunately they were as close as
they were and they have immediately
called for backup they responded as
quickly as possible they immediately
turned around raced back in the
direction where we'd seen the dog
unfortunately it's vanished which I was
worried about but there's not was not I
had to make a call and it was going into
a forest where I wouldn't have been able
to follow it anyway
so I'm helping them look for it
essentially hopefully we find us once we
find it then we'll gauge on its behavior
exactly what the situation is and it'll
probably most likely get transported
back towards the village and no harm
will come to it that is provided it's
not showing any signs of rabies and
rabies outbreak would have an absolutely
devastating effect on the animals out
here and that is something that is
definitely to be avoided
I think I can hear your name I think it
was Kalin possibly Helen I apologize I
can't fully hear Kirsty but you want to
know how rabies kills
sorry cursed I think you asked how
rabies kills its it skyrockets the
animals temperature it infects the brain
the lining of the membranes of the brain
and ultimately results in all sorts of
catastrophic events within the animal
itself so you'll get the symptoms of
excessive salivating hydrophobia in most
cases and then massive organ failure
from an incredibly high temperature and
dehydration dehydration will also play
an enormous role because as I said the
animals hydrophobic it doesn't like
water it's afraid of water
I'm just gonna focus quite hard while
there's still a little bit of light I'm
trying to help them find this dog they'd
send you back to a cross - Ralph I
couldn't hear what he has but that makes
it even more of a surprise odd facts I
did say we were looking for the big cats
and in particular lipids but we did find
something quite similar in name in a
couple of leopard tortoises now the one
in the front chair is feeding and the
other one is quite interested in it now
not sure if it's a male at the back it
was quite interested in the female in
the front or if it's a male sizing a
male which they can also do but quite
interesting there if the one on the back
film if you can go in nice and closely
they're on the scoots now that's what we
call those sort of blocks they're on on
the on the shell itself those are scoots
if you look at those scoots you can see
the ridges if you count those ridges
very similar to that of rings on the on
a tree if you cut a tree down and you
look at the Rings you can actually age
it so I'm just looking on the screen
here it's quite difficult to do just on
the screen without having being right
next to it but you can actually edge
them by Counting the little ridges on
the skin I would say this this small one
at the back is ranging between 12 and 15
years old so the one in the front I
would say is probably between 15 and 18
years old at least but quite interesting
that you can age them by those rings on
the scoot quite similar to that of fish
as well if you look at the scales of
fish very similar to the scoots of of a
tortoise and you can age them in exactly
the same way take a scale and you will
see the
rings almost identical to the scoots of
a tortoise and you will be able to edge
the fish now these are quite small
specimens if you look at how big
leopards can grow and already these two
are in the middle to later teams and the
one in front definitely looking like a
female and I think the one at the back
is a male indeed and that's just because
of that little tail section
it's obviously making it available for
the male to be able to mate now the one
on the back is underneath you can see
there is a little bit of an a sort of
indent where he would be able to climb
up on the female
question from Phillip wood would a male
mount another male as a sign of
dominance I haven't seen them mounting
each other what they do do however is
they bash into each other with their
shells and the idea being to actually
knock the other one upside down and
leaving him to possibly be exposed
upside down not being able to return
himself and insert in such way actually
kill him so I haven't seen the amount
each other they do have that indent to
enable them to be able to mount the
females shell itself to make it a little
bit easier I'm just going to reposition
for young to be able to view those
tortoises now the reason we do have our
roofs though on as I said is because
there is still a real possibility of
rain Noel took a bit of a gamble I'm not
a gambling man myself maybe it won't pay
off maybe it will but I'd rather be out
with the roof on anyway there does seem
to be a hot chase going on here between
these two tortoises and the one in front
is looking to be definitely like a
female but I love to watch tortoises
moving around now down in the Eastern
Cape where I am from they get three to
four times that size in general
obviously these ones can get that big
but on average in the Eastern Cape we
have the largest tortoises in southern
Africa and there you see them three or
four times the size of these individuals
that are moving off here and they get
about 80 kilograms they can live over a
hundred years and the Chelonia or the
shield reptiles one of the oldest
reptiles still living on the planet okay
since we've spotted those leopard
tortoises I think it's a good sign I
think it's a lucky sign we're gonna
start moving off
and we're gonna look for the namesake
there but the big cats and Jamie up in
Amara has got something a little bit
more horned oh we found ourselves a
rhinoceros in the search for the dogs or
not what I was looking for but it was
the direction that the the dog was
running in so I figured sitting still
might be just as productive as moving
about and since there's a rhino here I
would love to show it to you hey you
marching about of course it's nice and
cool and getting towards evening time
which is when the Rhino are their most
active they are essentially crepuscular
they spend most of the morning and the
evening wandering about and feeding they
do also move around a lot at night they
often go to water holes after dark so
there is a nocturnal aspect to their
behavior as well and this was actually
what the two Rangers were looking for
now well then you where it was roughly
and that was why they were in the area
that they were in because they're
actually dedicated to keeping an eye on
the Mara's Rhino should we go see if we
can get a little bit close to it might
take us some time to get around always
popping out and going away but I see the
road heads in that direction and again
it's the direction that the dog was
heading in so it that's bush I'm good
paranoia now looking all around me now
let's catch up with it quickly because
we'll get a really we should get a
really nice view
look like a male from the way that it
was urinating earlier it's difficult to
tell with size especially at distance
whether you're looking at a male or a
female rider but I think in this case
judging by the the backwards direction
of the urine it was a male here we go I
can see him up ahead I wonder how close
you'll let us come I saw him earlier
actually I didn't know he was here
but that was during the more frantic
search oh hold on everyone so the
Rangers know I'm in this direction
keeping watch as well so they have moved
we are it's all sort of rotating around
each other to look for it hello okay and
see your head up I know you look I know
you listening to me that's all right you
know what vehicles sound like
it's gonna if we keep going on the line
that we're in we're gonna be right up
close to it we should be wonderful and
rare not often we get to experience that
nice and slow
it's just gauge his reaction very
carefully I don't want to frighten him
but they are black rhino that are
completely comfortable
hello Billy who is five years old alone
welcome
now Billy wants to know how old rhinos
can get to they can live up to 40 years
old beliefs so they can actually get
quite old 40 years between 30 and 40
years hello my boy no no no no no no no
okay as soon as he backs down I'm gonna
back off because he is gonna definitely
thinking about giving us a charge hello
boy
don't do it so I'm talking because his
eyesight's bad I know I know I'd be full
of nonsense okay my boy all right
definitely a male okay all right soon as
he moves backwards I'm gonna move
backwards as well okay because as soon
as I start the engine there's a chance
he's gonna want to come straight at the
sound okay okay my boy all right you've
heard people before see I'm a person
yeah you might help a creature
okay here we go my boy here we go all
right yeah yeah okay so this is
indecisive still I've seen Rhino do this
they turn around and then they come back
again so we're just gonna sit nice and
still okay boy hey which way is the wind
blowing
it's barely blowing so what he's
probably gonna try and do is get
downwind of us so he might circle us a
little bit
just hold on a moment it's just wait and
see what he does because yes there is
he's coming around us that's what black
rhino often do so he's gonna try circle
hello boy okay okay it's calm down a lot
there we go so in a situation like that
obviously I don't want to frighten him
but he's now relaxed again and I could
cause more potential fear by racing or
revving away from him and also quite
honestly he's just like an elephant
he'll learn that that's a fun game and
he can chase cars away all I wanted to
do was talk to him now as soon as he
gets at a comfortable distance where I
can turn the engine on then I'm gonna
move away from him a mr. although he's
doing it all by himself
quite calm and relaxed now his thoughts
turning his head back towards the sound
of my voice but he's just moving off
sorry boy didn't mean to give you a
fright okay and off he goes so I've had
black rhino encounters where there are
as comfortable with the vehicle as as a
cow so they they can be entirely
entirely relaxed and already he's
relaxed again in our company so I'm
going to move off give him his space
carry on the search for the dog let's
head across to Brent who really truly is
having an afternoon for the scavengers
well this is very exciting I'm just very
sad this thing didn't appear yesterday
this is definitely a new bird for
everyone's moralists and Joe and I was
shocked when we saw it take off it's a
bit lost they're not supposed to occur
yet but it is a juvenile palm that
vulture
isn't that exciting that is a definite
first for me in the Mara we saw quite a
lot of them while we're in Uganda but I
didn't think their Kircher and I checked
my map and they don't but there we go
that is a lovely record of a palm not
vulture in the Maasai Mara I have to
speak to my birding friends see how many
of them have seen palm not vulture in
the Maasai Mara I think a few of them
were going to be a little bit jealous
wasn't that exciting you can see the
very distinct beak so palm nut vultures
are quite interesting they do a lot of
competing with fish eagles normally
around the big river systems and legs
and they will steal a lot of food from
fish eagles chase them off the fish that
the fish eagles of court now of course
they get their name the palm nut vulture
is because during or when the raffia
palms and start fruiting they are very
very fond of eating the palm fruit
and is so exciting I'm not vulture that
is a is a really big bird for the morrow
so yay
Oh more common bird for the morrow but
looking quite nice and puffed up after
getting a bit wet nuts it's normal call
hopefully it does its normal call
shortly and there's a white brown cuckoo
the rain bird let's hope it does it's
nice warbling call and you can see the
midges that are exploding out after the
rain buzzing around the Google okay
now we've got a lovely little vantage
points down to the Mara River at the
head yes let's go have a look I'm still
it's gonna be interesting to see I'm
gonna definitely come back through here
tomorrow because sometimes during big
storms problem juvenile prom night
vultures get blown around and appear in
areas where you don't expect them and
they can actually hang her on so I will
definitely come past chat tomorrow
morning and I'll hope that we'll be able
to get a bit of a better view of him and
maybe some baits and lights or her at
the moment is quite far away but they
can hang around so I'll show you their
their distribution when I stop after
going through the muddy muddy bits yeah
[Laughter]
once we get to the edge of the
Magnificent amara River
ah Larimore would like to know does that
vulture have a less bald head than the
other vultures indeed it does okay so
while we wait yeah I'll show you a
little bit better what there so as I was
saying its distribution there we go
so we are up here somewhere just up
there so you can see it's not
traditionally occurring in this area at
all when we were on the other side we
during our holiday we saw quite a few
Parmalat vultures but not on this side
so that was a really nice find for this
area and if we have a look at here we go
so it doesn't have a bald head at all so
I think we had a juvenile one that was
in between changing from juvenile to
adult colors so that there's the
juvenile there you can see the bald bear
around the eye they're very distinct
bull and that's what they look like and
if like they're very pretty birds when
they're flying from New Zealand says
Egyptian vulture next I would be very
excited to see an Egyptian vulture it is
one of my nemesis birds and I have not
seen it let me just I'll find you a
picture of Egyptian vulture now I've
been in places where people have seen
them just before in the Serengeti and
see I can't spell today there we go
that's the Egyptian vulture there so
it's the rarest one of the rarest of the
vulture species now also one of the only
birds that's quite well very clever and
what they'll do is they'll take bones
and they'll fly really high and then
drop them onto the rocks to open up to
get to the marrow so quite an
intelligent vulture and you can see how
spot there they might be here they can
be here but it's very very rare to see
them in this part they're much more
common up towards northern Kenya and
into Ethiopia
now we have some hippopotamus but before
we go to them we have some spurring left
wings on the little sand bank there no
Crocs today oh yeah hello lapwings let's
just move around the corner a little bit
so we can get a better view of those he
pushed my oh one got a fright it was
just below us but anything it realized
oh the male's giving some threat
displays opened his mouth oh no there's
a bit of an argument going on but they
got a bit of a fright sorry hippos here
we go calm down it's all okay now these
two seem to not be getting on too well
back there we go what's going on I
thought they might have a little bit of
an argument now Joe if we just look at
that wake that hippos up there now I can
tell you from being on small boats in
rivers like this all over Africa when
you see a wake like that coming for you
you really really do get a bit worried
and I've been in a few boats that have
been actually hit by hippos fortunately
we didn't capsize well they didn't put a
hole through the hippo
oh well through the boat one hippo I've
got a very big headache cuz he decided
he was very strong and he attacked a
stainless steel Braj and cam was sick
and best with a headache I'm sure okay
well we said yeah and enjoy the view of
the Magnificent murderous Mara River
let's go to Noel who's doing some
bedding so super jealous of burns palm
nut vulture very very very cool I
haven't seen one in a few months and I
last when I saw I was up in Zambia but
we do have a bird for you here we've got
a red crested Quran unfortunately this
Quran has
injured itself so we came up in a sort
of hobbling away and you can actually
see that how it's holding its one leg up
so it's either going to sort itself out
or unfortunately become food so it's
it's not necessarily the nicest thing to
talk about but it is something that to
talk about in terms of everything
functions within the ecosystem to
perform its role and then after it's
finished its role it then becomes food
it either it's body then goes into
becoming the nutrients in the soil or it
physically becomes food so this little
Quran I think is deciding whether or not
to keep trying to move with us here but
it's also keeping an eye on on these
little winged a lights that are flying
about and it's amazing how close it is
because we really are getting some nice
shots with the detail around the eye and
that you can see the textures of the
feathers along the head and a nice a
nice good look I've been busy over the
years taking photos of birds to put into
a slideshow just for myself like a bird
catalog so if there's any viewers out
there who are as keen as I am for
something like that this would be a good
one to do maybe there with a little bit
of a screen shot just to add into your
your your birding what what shall we
call it encyclopedia now we had our
birding big day yesterday and there was
a few people that are asking what apps
can I take off the apps that I
personally use and I know if several of
my friend uses the Roberts bird app but
also you can make your own from the show
and do do a PowerPoint like what I do to
to keep to keep my knowledge going off
shame buddy so that's a thought there
curses saying you had a Lapwing with a
sore foot this morning as well maybe
it's sore foot bird die shame these poor
guys it happens that when you've got
such slender legs and you're running
about as quickly as these birds do
especially these birds that do fly a bit
but dwell on the ground you are going to
to twist a foot every now and then so
with that bird up I was talking about I
know Tristan plays a lot of bird calls
for you I think Brent also likes to play
bird calls everybody so the calls are
also on there so that's also something
you can download and put put on your
PowerPoint but if you feel like a
project that might be a good project you
can do it with flowers because we're
coming into flowering season you can do
with the birds you can do it with trees
that we do I've also got a flower flower
power point going and Oh get it almost
not quite shame bunny okay well yeah
yeah I feel sad for him as well but
again everything happens for a reason
and it'll either sort itself out or it
won't and you can see it still is able
to to get around it's not kids not
completely out of commission but we will
leave you be our little feathered friend
maybe it's just a little bit of a sprain
David you're saying maybe we should take
it to the to the vet um so with the with
the wild animals again everything
happens for a reason and it's very
important to let wild animals be wild
also the the utilization of resources
for something like that those resources
are our most likely you better spent
somewhere else and it's it's
heart-wrenching and it's difficult but
you you kind of let to have to let
things be when when we as humans
interfere too much in the bush it can
sometimes have consequences that we
didn't necessarily foresee so as sad as
it is it's it's it's alright it's gonna
it's gonna what at what will happen will
happen and it will either sort itself
out or it becomes food for something
else that also needs to carry on and
live
Ralph has some crickets let's head over
to him all righty folks we just we're
doing a little bit a full bar flying and
we came to a little pan and we had a
little Jacobins cuckoo that we were
watching right there as he's flying off
as birds like to do as soon as we put
the camera on them very similar to that
the giraffe they like to move off but
we're moving through the thick stuff
yeah we were trying to follow up on
where the elephants had been sighted
near to one of the pans in the area
seems they've shifted off slightly so
we've just been going through the
through the thickets and we're just
gonna move a little bit forward I've
just seen some squirrels running around
in front but I like coming on these
lesser used tracks sometimes you never
know what you're gonna find
and it's masked to a little bit of a
feeling of discovery I can hear that
jacobins cuckoo calling now it's just a
ring necked of drinking hard and I've if
M can spot it over there there he is
something quite interesting watch what
he does
you see he's actually able to drink
straight now not all birds have got a
gullet and what you see there he's
drinking straight it's very similar to
that of a kori bustard where they're
done I have to bring their head up to
swallow back so they're actually able to
swallow with their head down not all
birds are able to do that so that's
quite something quite special with the
doves and the bustard the kori bustard
in particular I'm not quite sure if all
the bastards can do that I know the kori
bustard in particular can but the doves
can do that as well so and I'm sure
you've seen that especially a very
common one that you very sees like ducks
if they drink they take a couple of
mouthfuls and I have to literally lift
the head up and
swallowed that's because they don't have
a gullet but and it doves and bastards
do okay why are we watching this and
while I'm carrying on through the
thickets up in Amara Jamie's got a
lovely lion pride for you oh this today
is just full of unusual stuff this is
the N gamma pride this is the angle of
pride almost at the samake swamp this is
the furthest I have ever seen them in
this direction when is this lioness
digging for was she just digging for a
possible in a very cat-like manner for a
possible toilet spot well the Cubs are
playing too much there for it to be
anything like a warthog or anything like
that I have never seen the angle map
ride this far east that is not in itself
that unusual in this kind of situation
they spent a lot of time in one place
and they did that because they had young
cubs so they were Denning them there
it's just like what the Inca who
murdered and Kahuna pride did and
essentially it's it's to keep the cubs
safe and for them to grow up in a place
that they know but then once you get to
the point where the Cubs are large
enough to follow the lionesses and it
would mean that they're moving back into
the original all allure territory no
Yangon is in the old ola ole ole ola
pride are the same pride there's just it
was apparently a split so that would
make sense for them to be all the way
over here but I've also seen the three
Marsh break where lionesses but then
again territories are not set in stone
they are fluid
so to see them in a place where we've
never seen them before
at least explains we have a PE haein
gama's you've kept us very confused
now unfortunately I I can't stay with
them for too long and I have a
confession to make that's entirely
entirely my fault I'll be honest with
you I meant to ask for a ranger tonight
and I'm wrote the message and I didn't
send it and so when it came time to
leave I couldn't understand why there
was nobody ready to go with us and it
was entirely my fault
so I confess and I apologize I had too
much stuff happening in one at one time
I was busy trying to sort out the rain
covers on the vehicles and I just didn't
hit Send it happens to the best of us I
guess I hope but it does mean that we
are going to have to leave because we do
have to start rushing for the gate mad
my sincere apologies I would love to
stay with them I've never seen them here
before it's fascinating to see them here
and I'm very very happy to see them
again how do i oh hold on what is going
on in there
what have you found could it be it was
the war token well that's that if it is
those cups are paying a dangerous game
what it is they found I can't get any
closer it's a non off-roading area one
of those Cubs was trying to climb right
in there what's their alliance what have
you found
I hope it's not a water because if it's
a war talkative comes barreling out of
there at high speed there's good it's
going to be like bowling pins in terms
of Cubs flying about I don't think it is
though
I really are digging
looking so fascinated
deadhead Tom you say that you think it
would have been a warthog I think that
even the Cubs at this age would have
enough common sense to know that they
shouldn't be doing that if that is what
it is I would have thought because a
warthog is a dangerous thing even to an
adult line potentially especially
because they back into the holes and
they have razor razor sharp razor sharp
touches that could do severe injury
should they come flying out what it
could be as an art [ __ ] okay David did I
hear that correctly you said prairie dog
I don't think so unless it's very very
lost but although we have had an
afternoon of lost animals have we not I
don't think it's going to be a prairie
dog though I'm going to guess not
Mongoose maybe that could be as well
perhaps they're being playful they've
heard the Mongoose moving around and a
mongoose that's disappeared underground
come on the left just wants to play
really hey guys
wish I knew what was going on over there
fascinating okay I really I really do
need to go I would love to see how the
situation plays out oh okay let's just
what time is it
five minutes five more minutes just to
see how this what is going on here I'm
pushing it but five more minutes
I really want to know what's going on
cuz every now and again something gives
them a fright and they all jump
backwards and the Linus is very
half-heartedly digging there as well
she's quite full so they have eaten
recently possibly even last night and
that one young lioness cub is just not
giving up
Kestrel Fox has suggested a spring hare
all of these are possibilities I mean
apart from the prairie dog which is
unlikely and all of these are
possibilities because anything small
that moved might have attracted their
attention desperate desperate to see
what it is
I'm really curious
mom's putting a bit more work into it
now
what are you after what is in there if
something ran in there and they saw it
go in it would explain the obsession
that they currently seem to have is very
interesting a mystery
I shouldn't watch this for a little bit
they're not overly enthusiastic but it's
really really deep I mean they've opened
it right up
ten dead Tom me too then it Tom says
he'd hate for our first proper artifact
exciting my prefers provide for exciting
to be between a lion's teeth you know of
course for our new viewers I've never
seen an artifact I've got some kind of
artifact curse against me no matter who
sees them or where they see them I never
see them it's utterly bizarre it's it's
quite uncanny I've even been on an
artifact capture I have lived in a part
of the world where art farc sightings of
famous and I still haven't seen one I've
either been asleep or looking the wrong
way or something Linus has given up has
she was she going around the other side
I think she's going to give up the Cubs
might keep going for a little while
younger and more inexperienced
they are certainly dedicated to what it
was going on I wonder how long they've
been doing this
what is going on
now the Highness's moving back in now if
it is an artifact it is probably
tunneling as quickly as possible away it
could away from them Judy you say that
that you didn't know cats were diggers
they do dig in situations like this so
they Lions especially will dig out
something that's gone underground most
of the time they give up because
whatever it is that's escaped from them
is just too deep so they're not going to
carry on digging infinitum but they do
dig all and all of the big cats will dig
but a cheater won't dig out won't dig
something out of a hole but a leopard or
a lion will and a leopard will even
climb in after whatever it's it's going
for resting well the Cubs sticking their
heads down there
no they're resting not oh can you see
the dirt spraying around spraying away
from them something digging away as
quickly as it possibly can that's why
that was dirt there was dirt flying
there
that's what's been giving them a fright
I think it's an artifact I don't think
they'd be brave enough to all stand
right in front of where a water would
come flying out although you never know
injuries happen maybe this is how Lions
get injured when we don't see it happen
it could be very very foolish for them
to be standing in front of a water
borough like this at least for the Cubs
but they're big now and that hunting
instinct is powerful
amazing
I just wish we knew what was under there
if they're going to keep digging or if
they're going to give up you think
they'd cover the back getting sprayed
with faithfuls face face Falls of dirt
I do feel sorry for whatever's under
there can you imagine how utterly
terrifying that must be one Cubs given
up can you imagine how terrifying it
must be to be underground and you know
that there's lions digging their way
towards you gracious it must be
terrifying
the sound of the claws scraping do you
feel so sorry for it okay Martinez has
moved into prime position prime digging
position had holes deep
I think she's hit roots as well
oh she's hit another tail cub getting
covered in dirt blinking at her as if
say hey hey watch my face
[Music]
what are you after
first I can hear you I'm so sorry
how much longer can I stay technically I
was meant to be gone about five minutes
ago possibly ten minutes ago I just need
I do need to move though sorry arch I
need to move Hey hi good thanks how are
you did you see what went down there
what are they after it's okay thank you
I don't think so either but we'll try
Thanks where's I don't know I'm heading
back right now yeah yeah yeah yeah sorry
Oh Scotty I thought he asked me my
Ascari was that's a different thing
entirely Oh Scott's not out Scott's on
leave my bad Allison on such a question
I really really really need to go I
didn't I'm sorry I didn't know that it
was working we can do we can try it we
can try and do a two-minute one quickie
quick a quick action broadcast because
this is fascinating
we are losing light though okay let's go
um Eddie when you are so everyone we're
gonna be joined by a further audience
hello and welcome to a truly gorgeous
evening here in the Maasai Mara of Kenya
where we're watching an extremely
extremely interesting example of animal
behavior we've got a massive pride of
lions here and what you're seeing is
happening right here right now at
quarter past six in the Kenyan evening
it's cold and golden light and this
pride of lions that numbers 17 for
females and 13 Cubs have discovered
something underground now I've just been
told by one of the other guides in this
area that it was in fact a warthog that
has gotten racing off underground and
now we're watching them as they attempt
to dig it out now because this is live
it means that you can ask questions in
the comments section below so please do
send through your questions we'd love to
hear from you this could go on for a
very very long time but we just wanted
to show you this example of fascinating
behavior you can see the lionesses
panting she's tired
she's been working really really hard at
trying to dig this warthog out and nine
times out of ten a mission like this
will not be successful the cub on the
right of her is making an effort but not
succeeding particularly well David that
is very interesting isn't it lions don't
dig like dogs at all I have seen them
used to pause occasionally but most of
the time you are absolutely right they
use one porta dig completely different
to the approach that something like a
dog might take so she is indeed digging
with one paw but I think they've given
up Deborah in New Hampshire you say
jumbo well jumbo to you as well debryn
in New Hampshire it's wonderful to hear
from you I hope you are enjoying a truly
stunning sighting all Cubs are playing a
little bit but the lioness has got up
again is she going to keep digging I
think they're going to give up
in the scenario and I think that the
sport AAG is lucky then I was just
thinking imagine how terrifying it must
be to be that purpur waaaagh underground
listening to the sound of the Lions
trying to dig you out this is also very
very dangerous for the young Cubs they
don't realize but a warthog can be a
very strong creature and it's got very
sharp tusks so it could potentially
result in injury if it comes bursting
out now we have a question about how
deep the Lions can dig they're not going
to dig too deep they're not natural
diggers what they've done is they've
basically excavated an existing burrow
so the warthogs burrow could be easily 3
meters underground all the way down to
the bottom it will also have several
different escape tunnels Oh Cub dashing
back out you see the reflexes there now
the lioness is really going in philippi
you say hey that's hunting above-ground
is too mainstream the an gamma pride
which is the pride that we're with is
underground absolutely you could eat a
vita covered in dirt the cub jumped back
because the dirt went flying the
warthogs trying to dig itself even
deeper underground
Oh - getting cross to the cub probably
actually got scratched by its claws
while it was trying to help her dig it's
a young female cub around about nine
months old and desperate to help mum
loose re oh no there's no chance of the
cub getting stuck in the hole or at
least a very very slim chance the
warthogs been digging backwards so that
whole entrance is is covered in dirt
it's been desperately trying to dig
itself further underground so there's no
chance of the cub getting stuck however
there is a chance of the cub getting
very badly injured if the water table
comes running out a warthog can exit a
hole hurtling at speeds of around about
ten metres
possibly even 15 meters per second now I
imagine that at big water can be a
hundred kilograms a very big warthog
over 200 pounds imagine that racing out
at that sort of speed imagine the impact
that that would have with shark tusks to
be something phenomenally dangerous for
those Cubs
Catherine led the only way that they
could avoid tusks and injury would be to
launch themselves backwards as quickly
as possible
and hope that the water doesn't run into
them but an absolutely fascinating
citing this is - digging down deep she's
tiring I think in this case folks the
water's going to get away I don't think
they're going to manage to dig it out
can see she's panting she's exhausted
absolutely amazing so a really really
fascinating example of animal behavior
after we getting to see digging further
the ground is very soft at the moment
which is why she's able to do this Lyons
as we spoke about for aren't natural
diggers so she's able to do this because
there's been lots of rain in the ground
is very very soft she's exhausted hard
work especially when you've got a full
belly as she does none of the other
lioness is interested in helping her
they've all gone fast asleep and I think
this could go on for a very long time if
she doesn't get any assistance from the
adults this could extend for a very very
long time and so I think what we're
going to do is we are going to say
goodbye to those of you joining us on in
this action broadcast it's been
marvelous sharing this special example
of animal behavior with you live from
the Mara in Kenya so from myself and my
cameraman Archie who is bringing you
these wonderful images it's time for us
to say farewell but stay tuned for
further action broadcasts
okay that line is really really doesn't
want a VM doesn't want that Cub to come
too close we have to go we have to we
have to we have to go I've got a race
off so I'm going to send you a cross to
roughen juma and make my way to the gate
right folks we are we were we had some
lovely birding sightings while we were
while we were busy following up on on
some of the guys that just let me know
that there's some elephants in the area
while we were moving through we spotted
some what old starlings and that the
Jacobins cuckoo that I said was a
jacobins what's in fact I love violence
I didn't see that streaking on the
throat so sorry about that wrong
identification there but there's some
elephants in the area so we're just
going to come and have a look here
quickly at for your Taylor Dam and after
that we're going to continue on our
search for for those spotted cats but it
has been a little bit of time since
since we were notified that there was
some elephants here so we're just gonna
check if they're still in the area not
sure if they will be but we just see if
they here by the dam and after that
we're gonna continue does look like they
have in fact moved along
time and animals wait for no man sir
let's continue up over the damn wall and
then we'll head out onto the other side
and see if we can see those lipids
nobody's picked up on anything as yet of
real interest in terms of the bigger
cats it was only this elephant sighting
that I did want to follow up on but we
might still find them in the area down
at the waterhole now I can see there are
some niala so we'll just pop in and have
a look there while we on our way through
everything has been feasting on these
lights the flying termites as I said
before there's a whole host of Nuala
however on the other side they VM I'm
moving through the brush feeding as the
guy small bachelor heard of Anala bulls
quite content in each other's presence
no real dominance behavior going on at
the moment
normally when is a female around and
they'll start sparring and and squaring
up trying to work out who's who's the
boss so they're feeding quietly there
it's gonna move forward a little bit
let's see the awesome birds down yeah
looks like some Egyptian geese the
ever-present Egyptian geese
I'm still not seeing where these
elephants have disappeared but we'll
keep looking
coming and going as soon as the Sun
pokes through it is rather hot but still
got that very changeable feel to it
[Applause]
Chantal have have I or any of the other
guides ever been sorry what Kirsten in
control have I ever been what have I
ever been to Egypt have I ever been to
Egypt unfortunately I haven't been to
Egypt I would love to go and see the
pyramids and the Sphinx and all of that
I haven't been further north than Angola
and Zambia so Wow obviously I've been to
Europe but in southern Africa the
farthest north I've been is just over
the couny knee into Angola and just over
the Zambezi into Zambia so that's the
farthest north I've been I've traveled
extensively however in southern Africa
but once we cross over those rivers I
don't know much about it at all I have
been to Europe and the next side for me
would definitely be to have a look at
that northern part of Africa do you
really want to go into that area and see
what it's about but I think I find it
fascinating all that all that old
civilizations
nomads Anna and I and I hear that there
has been new discoveries even this year
of new tombs that they've discovered
within the within the pyramids and and
it's still a lot of that so unexplained
the level of how can I say you know the
civilization with them having the way
that they've built those pyramids and
but the technology should I say of some
is such a primitive we would say a
primitive civilization but with him
being able to design something like
they're actually having built it I mean
I've heard that a lot of people think
that there were some external powers
involved there it almost seems as such
because such a massive feat to being
able to build those things but humans
are very intelligence and I'm sure that
there are ways and means some big animal
tracks yeah but
right I'm going to continue searching
along yeah I'm looking up on these
elephants I'm also going to continue
looking for those cats but in the
meantime it's cost to know owl and see
what she is up to
oh I hope you enjoyed the cricket that
was actually a cuckoo oh sorry about
that
I had a good laugh so exciting up hey
Inez thank Akuma's are in biffle's hook
which is an exciting exciting because
hopefully from where I am at the moment
that they're gonna pop over but even
more exciting
out for leopard tracks to help out I all
sort of spread out across the prop to
give us the the best chat I mean
oh you on this side so Herbie is except
undie being around come join him in that
area and we're just
proofreads we think she's booting it
sounds
you
you
sorry about that everybody hit a little
bit of a rough patch there around
biffle's with damn so as I was saying
he's got some nice fresh tracks for
tündi and we oh sorry for the bumps we
are gonna go help him out so we are just
taking up the north and eastern part of
the area and hoping hoping hoping we we
pick her up she's moving the den sites
um which is good means that she's
possibly out for a and marking stroll or
maybe she's out for a little bit of a
hunt so seven I have our eyes peeled and
we are looking at all these Impala that
looked like they would be a good snack
for her but its life it's what happened
okay
let's head to Ralph's artifact we stole
heading along with we've just spun
around because we just want to have a
look in a completely different area so
I'm just continuing along and while I
was driving along I heard one of my
favorite little birds calling it's one
of our migratory birds and one of the
cuckoos and the way that we've always
remembered it and how we've always
taught our students when we training is
that he says I'm so sad he does them and
that's the black cuckoo I'm so sad and
he definitely sounds like he's very sad
to sharing some spoof owl making a bit
of a racket bothered them bumped by
something maybe it was an antelope
walking through up along the road
James question from James has there been
any reports of where those Buffalo or
natty have been seen recently or where
they've been moving the last I heard was
that they were up near Buffalo
so slightly towards the boundary and
maybe have hit it at present and it
seems like the Inka houma pride of lions
has been following them as well because
they haven't been seen now as well so as
soon as we had the Buffalo we had to
incur MERS and as soon as we haven't
seen them at the same with the Lions so
it might be the reason we not seen the
groomers and probably
so just carrying on our own along the
road here a little bit really just
looking to show you something
interesting as game drives go we just
try and find whatever we can along the
way and have some lovely things for you
but that's the way it works if we if we
stop in one spot we see some lovely
things and then as soon as we cut back
to us do they move off that's the luck
of the draw isn't it but we won't stop
trying now where are these kitty cats
waiting to get some sign of them
everybody is fan dot we all talking to
each other and trying to find out if
anybody's had any sightings had any
signs and nothing as of yet just keep
going let's not forget folks next week
well it is Sunday today for us in the
bush it's it's another bush day but I
know it is Sunday today tomorrow Monday
being the start of Arbor week and we're
gonna do lots of trees so I'm not gonna
stop for cheese today this morning I did
with the false marula and I gave a
little bit of an explanation there but
I'm going to do lots of trees next week
for Arbor week
I'm just gonna try and concentrate on
finding some of those bigger cats I'm
also in the position to identify all the
individuals at the moment and I want to
I've got the whole family tree and
everything now but I'm gonna continue
along the way it seems my signal it's
going on so let's cross Noel and see
what she has all right I have not found
anything as of yet still on the hunt
Herbie is now on foot tracking through
the block and we are busy checking the
road so we've got a two-pronged approach
to find our gorgeous a ton d and
hopefully be able to show her on screen
so something that we had chatted about
this afternoon before we left Ralph deny
is because of all the moisture we had
yesterday
that a lot of the cat species will be
out marking territory which is good for
us and it was warm today but it's not
too warm it's not it's not so warm that
everything will be want to be lying in
the shade it is a good temperature for
things to be moving during the daylight
so I am as always forever hopeful so
what we are doing now is every now and
then I'm just checking game paths that
come off just to see maybe if she
crossed and just checking in the road a
little bit to see if I can pick up
anything there and then also just
checking for her herself not just her
tracks so it's from what Herbie was
telling me it looks like he says that
she was busy drinking water and then was
sort of stalking something near that pan
and so to me that possibly means not
only she out marking territory but that
she's also very hungry and of course she
would be hungry she's got her cubs in
her den we still as far as I know don't
know how many as the dens been shut down
for now while they're still so teeny
teeny tiny but hopefully around new
year's time we will be able to see them
maybe a little bit before but my
guesstimate is going to be New Year's I
do know Kula who is a beautiful leopard
s that's many many years ago I saw for a
few times she was very relaxed and you
said like to bring her youngsters out
quite early
Thandi I'm not quite sure to me I think
she would probably be like a normal
effort and sort of wait about three
months but I don't know viewers you must
tell me can you remember what age she
brought out her last set of Cubs to show
to the world
be interested to know building up the
information for this area
so also while we're driving like this we
are also going to be checking inside of
trees maybe we get lucky and she's made
a kill for us already
oh so it's just a really gorgeous
afternoon
good temperature smells nice
smells like summer smells fresh white
African soil smell not the same as red
soil red soil has a different smell but
the sort of low felled slightly humid
very balmy afternoon
we're also going to have a nice sunset
for the first time in a couple of days
which will be lovely
fantastic question Phillip Phillip
you're asking which species removal
would cause the longest domino effect
now Phillip for me I actually think it
would be bees I don't know if everyone
has been following the concern over the
past few years with bee species numbers
plummeting without bees we don't have
tomatoes we don't have avocado avocados
we don't have coffee we don't have many
of the things that make my life very
happy avocados and coffee being two of
them but they're pollinating and the way
that they function the ecosystem is
integral for our survival as humans but
also for the survival of much of the
rest of the the world's sort of
biosphere so Phillip I would say sorry
little spider I would say bees honey
bees that would be my guess that's a
really fabulous question Phillip are you
pondering serious thoughts this
afternoon
because as you know I always love a good
discussion
Catherine you're saying you agree and
say yes poor bees I also say that I'm
also just amazed it with something like
bees being so integral to our food
resources and as you know we as humans
are very particular about how we
function in the ecosystem I'm surprised
that there hasn't been more study on the
bee issue and what's been happening with
the bees sorry guys I just want to
triple check my map very very quickly
and just make sure that I am going where
I need to go for her bee
I'm wondering if he needs me to go
farther north on dog let's do this
portion of drakensberg and and see what
happens so I've got most of the roads
and juma down by now but every now and
then it's nice to take a look at the map
for me and just sort of gauge distances
for for me I'm very used to quite large
areas and so the spaces between roads is
very large and big and wide and here
it's a little bit smaller so it's taking
me a little time to adjust
shirring you're curious if I've ever
followed a honey guide Sharon I haven't
but I would be fascinated to do that I
have friends who have tried it and ended
up nowhere and also ended up with with
honeycomb so yeah no I haven't but I
think that would be super interesting so
I curse you're saying someone did it
live on the show and it worked
Steph to the Beehive oh that's fantastic
very very very cool I know and for
anyone that's wondering what we're
discussing honey guides and following
and beehives there's a story about
Greater honey guides in particular which
is a type of bird who makes a very
specific call when it either finds a
human or finds a honey badger and if you
follow if it makes this call and you
follow it it will lead you to honey but
then they say that you must make sure to
give it some of the honeycomb
because if you don't the next time it's
call will lead you to a black mamba so
that's very cool now my pondering
thought for the day off of our our honey
guide step didn't give it honey Oh guys
well next time we see Steph on camera we
better remind him it came with some
termites all right that's not so bad so
honey guides have the ability from birth
to be able to digest honeycomb and as
far as I know they're the only bird
species that's able to break that down
so now it's sort of the chicken in the
egg factor when they're born with this
ability does it does it mean that it was
a learned habit from the honey guy that
eventually led to the evolutionary
attractive being able to digest that
honeycomb or where they just
automatically born with it that's my
pondering thought for you all to ponder
today
my my fact for the day haven't really
been doing FAQ for the day recently I
think I need to come up with some more
facts for everybody
willow wander you're saying that the
first time that you saw tomba which is
tondee's most recent cub it was three
months and one day after the fact which
is pretty normal leopard behavior thank
you very much for that information
so he's interesting to me there was a
female that I used to work with on
another property named ish and Gil a and
she was super super super relaxed with
with us and her cubs and I mean we used
to end up in this the craziest scenarios
with her and and you would think that a
normal leper would be like I'm gonna eat
you get away and she's gonna go I don't
mind that you're standing there and my
Cubs on the other side of you welcome
this is hers you know she's to me was
the craziest thing and that was just her
personality now her daughter and below
who's my favorite leopard of all time
and below means heart and below is not
like me lows I go away go away go away I
want to have nothing to do with you when
I've got these things welcome and then
one of her daughters who used to be
called one three female she still called
that I'm she as well she was like uh-uh
I want nothing to do that
sorry we're having a little bit of
signal issues as I come through Mumma
walked II here so let's head on over to
Ralph and I'll see you just now
FX we've continued on once again looking
for those elusive lipids but we've come
across a lovely little herd of male
impala near two twin dams and they've
been doing a little bit of sparring and
so on as we made our way towards them
and even fvm can have a look on the
Rotch oh we've got our hottie dog ibis
and i know up in the tree on the
left-hand side I was told that there's a
lovely nest of of these guys in this
Jaco berry tea sir and they're walking
around just probing for all sorts of
worms and grubs and things in the grass
would be it would be lovely now off to
the rain ground is nice and soft and
lots of things coming to the surface so
just gonna move forward a little bit and
so that we can get a nice view of this
waterhole we might actually see some of
these animals moving forward and
starting to drink a little bit nervous
just watching them you know animals will
get nervous once they move down towards
the water anyway because they they do
become a little bit vulnerable but it's
a lovely group of Impala day they're all
in prime condition and we don't always
just want to race and try and find the
leopards we do need to sit and watch
some Tom's because we don't want to miss
any action in between you never know in
a leopard might pop his head out there's
a couple of miles they're just starting
to spar a little bit
Oh is lovely to watch Impala as well and
I will be mocking as well as I move
along they're all still fighting with
trees and bushes as they move along you
can see them that you know they're
working on their neck muscles it also
helps them for when they're sparring
with each other all these males are good
lovely sets of horns yeah locking horns
I've actually seen when a couple of
Springbok up in the desert have actually
locked horns honestly that they couldn't
they couldn't get themselves free and
both of them eventually died and then
was scavenged on but they literally
fought themselves to the death but it
was mine mainly down to the fact that
they got locked and I couldn't get their
horns on and uh niched there's a bird
calling out of the left side chairs were
always going Maggie Maggie Maggie
crosses cookie that's a great little
piece of sparring going on me once again
we in that time of their the sort of
false rut I've mentioned why the females
dropping their babies that increase in
estrogen creates a increase in
testosterone with the males so they do
you start to spar a little bit between
themselves as well so it is a little bit
quieter
other than those Impala and a few birds
that are calling we am NOT gonna such a
much longer I think we're gonna move on
of it we're actually heading for Chitra
damn we're gonna go up there and see if
we can spot some baby crocodiles
lilly h 5 asking the question if monkeys
can swim belly I have seen monkeys
swimming but they generally don't really
like the water too much you can see that
they sort of they sort of walk in the
water with their arms out the water like
this so and early they they defeat
touching so that they really look
uncomfortable
totally Billie and they don't generally
want to go into the water either because
they're quite scared of crocodiles and
there's always that threat and near down
to the water that can also be that that
possibility that a leopard is waiting in
a big tree nearby so they don't
generally go for a swim per se but I
have seen them crossing water and going
through river small rivers but I haven't
seen them sitting and enjoying a swim
but they I'm sure they can adapt in the
water and they're not the best of
swimmers I would say Lily so we're
hitting up the cut line here now you're
gonna go and see if we can find some
interesting things up the chitwa dam
always along the way we always on the
lookout looking for those cats that are
pre marking their territories
and it's getting to that time of day as
well that Suns starting to dip it's
starting to cool off nicely
it's predator time always look up the
little drainage lines in the rivers
prime area sorry for the bumps folks
just going up the other side of this
little drainage line through the river
bed heating up along the road lovely
fresh cool breeze coming through now
cooling off nicely and it seems like
Noelle's gamble paid off the rain hasn't
come and we set with our with our roof
on making it a little bit difficult for
ourselves but we thought that the Rhine
Mart he does a little bit and we thought
that we'd it'd be the one smiling at the
end of the day that looks like Noelle's
gonna be the one to be enjoying it more
than us
Kristen from Ellie have I got a favorite
lipid on Juma yet well I definitely do
Ellie because when I did my interview Dr
Tandy was very obliging and she helped
me through my interview drive she lay on
the road she let us follow her she even
had a crested Franklin charger which she
had to his set and try and chase away
and when she got up and moved off the
Franklin continued to hunt her down
but for now Tandy is definitely my
favorite lipid so you can tell us who
yours is as well let me know at the
moment I'll take any leopard but dandy
would definitely be a treat Shawna has
also been very obliging with him showing
us his kill up in the marula the other
day
those are the two I've really enjoyed
watching this ride is a little bit more
used by vehicle so it's got these
corrugations on it which makes for the a
little bit bumpy on the camera as you
can see now those corrugations generally
occur when you've got a lot of vehicles
driving through and as they accelerate
or break but mainly when they accelerate
it makes little little dunes and as soon
as there's a tune then the vehicle goes
over and the wheel spins a little bit
more it makes the junior and bigger so
that's why you'll see when you start to
get these roads being used a little bit
more you start to get these corrugations
and that's what's making the camera
bounce of it early thanks for your
response and shadow being your favorite
leopard I don't think I have seen shadow
of yet as yet so I still wait to see her
shadow being Tandy's sister that's
that's fantastic I really want to see
her and I'll really like to put on the
video for you as well so thank you for
that Ellie we're heading down towards
Chitwood a.m. now and I'm sure it's
gonna be full of hippos and lots of
birds
caller your favorite being Tomba and
husana well that's understandable there
are two beautiful animals on tape doing
all my research trying to find out about
all the individuals Wow we've got a bird
of prey flying off there looks like a
Wahlberg's Eagle and we're gonna follow
him down towards the water so like I was
saying I'm doing my homework on all the
individual lipids and I would like to be
able to identify them and know them by
name but I'm still new here so I'm gonna
try and learn them with you obviously
for the seasoned viewers you can
indicate to me once we find them there's
a couple of Wahlberg's Eagles here being
mobbed by its most likely a full tail
drongo we just freewheeling down the
road because I think that that predators
gonna disappear off into the distance so
sorry about that that I just carried on
guy but we're just heading down now
towards the water and VM told me that
he's looking to see some baby crocodiles
kaby asking the question if you want to
guard in South Africa what would be your
job well there is a number of places
okay be asking what would be a job if I
wanted to be a guide in South Africa the
way would I want to guide I think excuse
me sorry they were just clearing up
there if I wasn't a guide
what would my job be what would I choose
to do I really I always wanted to be a
pilot and that was one of the things
that I always wanted to do and I always
wanted to be a professional surfer so
those were two things that I always
wanted but my father always said to me
that I needed to get a proper job so
even whereas being a guide he still says
to me I need to get a proper job but I
do think that it is it's a proper job
isn't it so at least now he can see your
ID so there's a difference in that VM I
wonder if we should if we should head up
along the wall and see if we can see the
Crocs along the island that might be an
idea we'll have a look along the wall
and then we might take a look behind the
wall and see if there's any of our
spotted cats hiding behind there it
seems that Noelle might be in the area
but we'll continue along here anyway
it's not the best that we're both in the
same spot that
we will have a look down here regardless
thanks for all the questions and
comments folks it's nice that you
interacting it's great that we can
answer your questions and get involved
we're up here this morning and we had a
lovely time birding I think there's a
crocodile after water on the island
sorry my mistake that was a log that
looked like a crocodile
easy enough mistake to make I lock it
off thanks Kirsten and love it all nice
one right I think I'm gonna back up a
little bit and we're gonna go down just
down behind this wall here and have a
look and see reversing Safari now drive
a great speed okay while I do my
reversing Safari and go down behind the
wall and see if any of those spotted
cats are there let's see what Noel is up
to are we live all right hi everyone
so herbie has done some expert tracking
and what he's found not only with
Tunney's tracks but also a drag mark I
don't know if you guys can see these
marks here this is a drag mark from I
would guess a male Impala from what I
can tell from from the drag marks here
we're just trying to ascertain direction
at the moment to me I'm not getting her
tracks just now but it looks like she's
moving this side looks like she's moving
this side possibly with it so
we're just going to try and see what we
can find
regarding this I just need a little bit
more time to move in the area and to
check everything and then hopefully
we'll be able to find her on foot so if
you all wouldn't mind just give me a
couple of minutes just so I can have a
really in-depth in-depth look and then
be able to piece the story together with
Herbie so that everyone can see that
would be super great I just want to have
a quick look around a little bit farther
afield okay folks sorry I just changed
my mind a little bit I just wanted to
come down the end of the dam here just
to see we might be able to spot some of
these this thank you some little baby
crocodiles in so we just want to have a
quick check and then I'll turn around
and head back towards that the bottom of
the dam wall and you'll see if any of
those cats are down there that's his
favorite spot of them just out of there
with him is a green back here and looks
like he's got a fish and he just
swallowed a draught down how's that very
good hunters as you can see and with
that bow being a spear like weapon and
he's right back to hunting mode it did
seem not he's just trying to wash down
that meal yet and we haven't seen a
lipid or lipid kill as it but we've
we've definitely been seeing the birds
having a feast this afternoon not seeing
any crocodiles at the moment
having a look around the hippo with its
little baby is just a father here and
sorry for that pole once again little
baby keeps popping up and down next to
mommy the Dietrich's cooking calling the
ddddd Drake's he says the Derrick's
lovely setting pan out there you can see
that son talking through it's a lovely
color to getting it present I'm checking
on the other side a lot of Egyptian
geese
I didn't do it asking a question how
much can I hear in heat in one sitting
well it's like all of these birds we
were we were watching those wattle
starlings earlier eating termites until
they literally looked like they were
gonna pop but like this this pimple
green-backed hearin if the fish were
readily available I think they would
need quite a lot and almost to the point
where they would they would be on the
verge of popping so it's quite difficult
to judge
that's quite a small little hearing net
that green-backed hearin but something
like a grey heron or black-headed heron
they're quite large birds and they would
obviously be able to eat a whole lot
more
but how much exactly and probably be
able to eat three-quarters of the body
weight in one setting and then and they
would probably sit for a day or two
trying to digest it but they are able to
quite a lot of food especially when the
going is good and the resources are
available it's like your penguins in the
sea when when the sardine run is on and
the sardines are readily available that
will feed until they are almost not able
to move it's like the gannets that fly
down there also they can't even fly
eventually and their vm is just going in
on the Red Bull Buffalo Weaver's nests
when I get once again okay so we've
we've hung around here we haven't been
able to see any of these baby crocodiles
it's a very serene it's full of birds at
the moment the wind is cutting across
the water a little bit creating a bit of
a ripple it's very cool on the opposite
end of the water we've got some water
back moving down towards the water they
they also line down ruminating a little
bit
it's a lovely scene here an extension to
them there's a hippo coming out of the
water a little bit and moving across
it's almost time for them to be able to
come out of the water and start feeding
there's these mommy with the tiny baby
once again you can see even from this
distance you can see that pink around
their eyes and did you see how that baby
is very playful jumping around be time
for them to go out the water soon one
real human question is that baby
suckling under water not not
particularly now it's quite difficult
for him to hold his breath he can only
hold his breath for a few seconds at
this age so he would wait for mommy to
be either standing in the real shallows
or moving out in the evenings so it's
quite difficult for him to hold his
breath so he won't be suckling
underwater and you'll see mommy tries to
lift him up every now and then all the
all the viewers with the coots and hums
and aahs it's it's lovely to watch these
babies you know it's that time of year
as well all the animals start to have
the babies and right next to us it was
indeed a little baby with this mommy
here TVM I thought I was being I was
being a bit silly but he is a little
baby there and if you wait on him you
will see the little baby pop up
initially when we arrived I thought
there was a little baby and then I
thought it took too long for him to come
up and I thought maybe I was being silly
but it is in fact one and if you wait a
little while you'll see the little a pop
up just to the right of where the mummys
eye is showing there there we go see see
I can't hold this bed for too long and
if you popping up every now and then yes
I think this is quite a big scar on the
back of the zipper and that would
actually cut if you're looking at it now
it's quite a lot of blood there now even
now not just the scar it's fresh wounds
they it's almost like this and this
animal has had some ions going at it I
wonder
unless it's had some fats with what some
of the other hippos which is also a
possibility because I do think if this
if this mummy was got at by the Lions
I'm sure that baby would have been an
easy target but with mummy that sighs
maybe she fought him off so for me it's
either that she's had a run-in was one
of the other hippos or she's had a
run-in with a predator during the
evening that's quite interesting
question from Sheila what the baby girl
ooh sorry Sheila wants your question now
but you see this red Bulldogs picket
actually feeding on those on those
wounds and they can sometimes be
parasitic like it's doing now it's
actually feeding on that on that wounds
and I can often do that with
Impala giraffe they'll actually take off
some of the parasites and then I'll keep
the wound open and they'll feed on it
certainly see it's actually being
parasitic now it's not actually helping
that hippo at all so the question was
would that baby go with the mummy to
feed at night yes absolutely that baby's
gonna stay near to the mummy wherever it
goes she would take it and she would try
not to go too far but the baby would
stay she wouldn't leave it with anybody
else and she wouldn't just drop it here
in the one leave a chair in the water
either
so that baby's gonna be accompanied by
mum or the other way around whichever
way you want to look at it but these two
will stay together wherever they go okay
so like I said we're gonna move off from
the CIPA in a minute and we're gonna go
down the ladder will the damn wall
looking for those spotted cats in the
meantime we can crust in a while and see
what she has been looking for or finding
all right Herbie and I had a look around
Herbies assessment is that it looked
like she maybe caught a small warthog so
we're just busy circling the block again
and on our way around the block we found
this beautiful site for everybody so I
think let's just take our moment of
appreciation for the bush and I'll be
very quiet and we can watch this
gorgeous sunset and listen to the bush
sounds
absolutely gorgeous as that Sun slowly
filtered its way through those clouds
towards the horizon and as always the
colors are absolutely incredible I hope
you all could hear all the beautiful
Bush sounds in the background there's
some oxpeckers going it's an Egyptian
Keis it sounded like a barred outlet off
to the back the only thing we're missing
is that saw saw saw noise of Tunya who
is somewhere hopefully not far from us
absolutely spectacular I hope you all
enjoyed that as much as I did
thank you sub as always with your
brilliant camerawork yeah all right
shall we carry on keeping and looking
for our lovely lady Tandy Jersey lady
you're saying that this would be a
beautiful wallpaper for your desktop I
hope that you managed to get a nice
screen shot I would absolutely agree it
is a beautiful beautiful beautiful
setting all right the only thing that
was missing is on one of those dead
trees with look it's a little bit small
but tündi lying there with her little
dead warthog shame her bees been working
so hard all afternoon and it's so tough
that the soil is very hard around there
so you can see where there was a bit of
struggle in some of the looser soil and
then everything gets gets quite hard so
I'm I'm crossing fingers and holding
thumbs and we're gonna do our best to
help them out and sort of circle this
spot here but of course you know how I
all love a sunset and showing you all
the sunsets we couldn't miss that also
nice just to sort of sit and listen
because when you sit and listen you can
sometimes either pick up alarm calls or
pick up calls from her you never know
okay coming back towards our little pan
here
and
trusting that it was just a little
warthog that she caught I originally had
thought it was horns but actually drags
from from the the warthog itself just
let's trust let's just say from what we
could see that it is a small one it
would mean that she would have finished
it quite quickly and then hopefully
started moving again so now I just need
to ascertain but where did she move to
and unfortunately it's starting to get
dark so where we were having a look
Herbie could only walk around for a
little bit longer and then I I decided
to get back in the car and sort of drive
around and to try and utilize what
little bit of light we have left to to
get the sighting if possible so I think
while I'm busy doing that let's head
back to her off and see what he has to
say we've just come towards the airstrip
we had a look around the damn wall there
wasn't much action there after the
hippos and this was where the yesterday
by James hang around in a similar area
so like VM said we've got double the
chance there with two males in this area
yesterday we just went to try our luck
and see if we can spot one before the
end of the show quite lucky if we do
never know we're just gonna give it a
chance look in all of these gorillas
trees that are ideal lying up spots
the airstrip
okay I'm in front of us
thanks for the comments Debbie let's
cross to Noelle she's got a bird for you
how amazing is this we have our Walberg
Eagle pair the the light more sorry I'm
so excited the dark morph and the light
morph and they're busy picking out the
winged a lights on the ground just here
so these winged a lights these termites
are super super high in protein I know
that you saw earlier with Ralph he had
the vervet monkeys that were eating them
but this is just absolutely absolutely
fantastic the other reason why it's so
incredible as there's a confusion of
guinea fowls that's not far off from
them that is absolutely having a fit
look look look
having a fit that these birds of prey
are down here on the ground and they're
sort of circling them and they're
calling and clucking but at the same
point the guinea fowl are also going for
for the wing a lights this is very very
very cool for me this is better than a
leopard I love leopards and I love I'm
so excited at the thought of possibly
seen tündi but this is incredible it's
not often that you get to see birds of
prey especially Birds prey of this size
doing what we're seeing here yes I love
summertime the last time that I saw you
can see that can e-file coming in said
to the left it's like they're taking the
same pathway just listen for a sec
sorry curse just say that one more time
Carla said Carla you're saying it looks
like the Wahlberg's are wearing pants it
does so Carla a a factor a physiological
look of a true Eagles that they have
feathers all the way down the legs so
Wahlberg's are in fact a tree eagle with
those feathers down there and it does it
does look like they're wearing pants
so guinea fowl are absolutely freaking
out
I've been eating at the same time this
is hysterical
Wahlberg's are so I'm concerned with
those guinea fowl and just really after
those those winged air lights the last
time I saw something like this I was in
the car aha tea transfer tier Park which
is in the north western side of South
Africa and it joins in with Botswana and
borders on Namibia it's one of my
favourite places it's a brilliant place
to camp and we were there in February
and it had rained just a little bit and
every sort of bird of prey you could
think of was on the road like this going
after the harvester termites that were
coming out on the road
notice how the guinea fowl start to
quiet down a little bit they're still
giving a wide birth to these Wahlberg's
but they they're after the same food
source so they're there they're putting
aside their differences predator prey
difference and just going at these
termites
I don't know about everybody at home but
I am over the moon with this I think
this is the best part of my day thus far
this is a really amazing sighting
it's interesting some of you are
wondering many of you are wondering are
the the Wahlberg's gonna go after the
guinea fowl I'm gonna say no and I'm
gonna say no with some some great
certainty I think if they were gonna go
after the guinea fowl they already would
have done so I really think this is sort
of like a peace treaty like hey listen
we are after the boat the same food
source there's enough of the food source
for all of us let's just enjoy this
moment I mean every now and then that
pale morph there pushes away a guinea
fowl but but yeah just to get to the
Allied says there's there's no no
intention they're also just as a thought
as we're thinking about this um I
Wahlberg's will go for other bird
species but I would be interested to see
them go for something as large as a
guinea fowl I've seen one try I haven't
seen one get it I've seen through
Marshall Eagles get guinea fowl a little
bit easier Marshall eagle is about twice
the size of these Wahlberg's not to say
that they're off the menu but that could
also be part of the reason why is that
it's on the periphery of their their
prey size
this is so incredible so those winged a
lights not only will the birds of prey
eat them and the guinea fowl eat them
you saw the monkeys eating them we can
eat them as well they're actually quite
nice if you fry them up in a pan it's
almost like peanut butter it is probably
the only insect that I enjoy eating was
Ralph's office also say the same thing
that's hysterical yeah yeah they're good
there I know any of you that have been
watching for the past several weeks when
jean Dre was on camera with me he kept
trying to get me to eat all sorts of
insects and I was like no I'm not going
there but winged out lights out eats
there they're quite good
I'm glad Ralph's suit feels the same
favor Devin you're curious if in the
same clutch of eggs the Wahlberg's will
have pale and dark morph there's also a
buff morph the buff morph is a bit tawny
so as far as I can think off the top of
my head they have one to two eggs but
they only raise the one chick so I to me
the answer would be yes and then it's
just whichever chick they decide to
raise is that being the healthiest and
the strongest is then the one that comes
up and so it could be buff morph could
be a pale morph could be a dark morph I
don't think they're looking at to any of
those morphs in saying oh I like this
more Thal it'll bit better but but yes
you you can definitely definitely in the
in the same in the in the same clutch I
can't see why not genetics wise but they
will only raise the one young I've seen
battlers dark morph pale morph and tawny
morph now it's interesting because it's
not in my book you don't necessarily see
all those morphs but I've seen them
side-by-side one was extremely dark one
adult believe it was the male the female
was a sort of normal-looking battler and
then their offspring that was an adult
offspring with adult plumage was much
more of a lighter color a Buffy air
color it was it was very interesting so
as we know the the battlers have go
through a stage for about six to seven
years where it takes them to get their
adult plumage into that beautiful white
and black and a little bit of a tawny
but in that actual plumage they had that
third one that was there that had slight
tinges and had been seen from many years
on the property sort of going through
its adult stages and then popped up like
that it's very interesting as well and
actually Ralph and I were chatting about
this depending on what area of the
country you work in is whether or not
you've seen some of these morphs
particularly of the of the Wahlberg's
I've been very lucky in a lot of the
places that I've worked where I've seen
the tawny or the started the buff morph
the the dark morph and the pale Mort and
Ralph was saying until he'd actually
come up here I believe he hadn't really
seen the pale morph and when I was
working in northwest province we had
more of the pale morph and less from
what I remember and less of the dark
morph
and I hardly ever saw saw a buff morph
and then here I've seen I think four or
five pale Mars and and that that dark
morph just just in the month that I've
been here it's pretty interesting so I
don't know if there's also maybe a
genetic pool per area not necessarily on
purpose but it just happens to be that
way as a thought I don't have a full
answer for you but just as a thought
curious to think about I'm still so
fascinated by the sighting
I'm credible we had those Lions digging
with with Jamie with the Paul not
vulture with Brent
we had the wonderful vervet monkeys
eating the winged a lights with Ralph
and now we've got the guinea fowl having
a truce with the Wahlberg's Eagles
eating these winged islets as well it's
really been such a fascinating afternoon
that that Walberg just decided that was
enough the guinea fell over to close so
now as it starts to get dark the a
lights will come out a little bit more
but then the Wahlberg's will make their
way back home and roost as will the
guinea fowl they will also also roost so
you must join us a tomorrow morning at
five o'clock our time and hopefully
we'll get more amazing sightings like
this thank you so much for myself
Ralph Jamie Brent Seb viim everyone in
FC you must have a wonderful wonderful
evening
you